frère et qu'il reste encore plusieurs
canadiens là qui sont emprisonnés à
travers le monde mais en fait il ya 1500
en date d'aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
détenus dans les prisons majoritairement
aux états unis majoritairement aussi
pour des crimes et délits qu'ils ont
commis il ya quand même des dossiers qui
sont soutenus par amnesty international
et ce sont des dossiers dans lequel il
ya eu probablement abus de pouvoir la
torture également par exemple en chine
il y à un cas il est emprisonné depuis
avril 2007 c'est hussein ces litiges en
fait il était accusé de complot
separatist il est en prison à perpétuité
là bas non loin de là du côté de la
corée du nord et bien nous avons un
pasteur monsieur solim qui est
emprisonné depuis janvier 2015 et là il
a il ya quelques semaines de cela dû
avouer devant les caméras
gouvernementale qu'il allait il avait un
projet de renverser le régime
avec en fait la force de dieu bref qui
voulait instaurer un régime religieux
qui est assez particulier quand même du
côté de la corée du nord aux émirats
arabes unis
il ya en fait salim al aradi qui eût ça
fait un an qui est emprisonné il ne sait
toujours pas pourquoi on n'y a pas
signifié qu'il était son acte
d'inculpation c'est quand même étonnant
bashir makhtal en ethiopie depuis 2009
il est emprisonné
john baird alors ministre des affaires
étrangères avait tenté de le faire
transférer au canada son succès depuis
son dossier est un peu perdu et puis
aussi les cas selon un incident
international de détenus canadiens qui
attendent dans le couloir de la mort
leur exécution aux états unis et
traditionnellement le canada essayer
d'obtenir la clémence et pour ces deux
là et depuis quelques années ça ne se
fait plus donc ça c'est déploré par une
scène internationale le cas de malades
familles bien sûr elle était très
médiatisé sa peine cause c'est laid mais
c'est pas la seule cause célèbre
évidemment omar khadr vient tout de
suite à l'esprit vous savez il a passé
de longues années à guantanamo
bon maintenant il a retrouvé une partie
de sa liberté il est aussi revenu au
canada il y avait aussi rappelé vous
maher arar qui avait été
emprisonnés torturés en syrie pendant un
an pour finalement se faire libérer
alors que la syrie n'avait rien contre
lui
et puis un cas qui a mal tourné aussi le
libano canadienne zahra kazemi qui avait
été arrêté une photographe pendant qu'il
prenait des photos de manifestants
arrêtés torturés trois semaines plus
tard on l'avait retrouvée morte
oui malheureusement merci faudrait